I don't think that is being overly
optimistic or if it is I'm right there
and I think a lot of other people who
care about creativity creativity not
just for the sake of art itself but
creativity as a way of looking at
problems looking at human beings looking
at the world from a number of different
angles at the same time I think that
what we've seen from a lot of Obama's
political utterances that I think is
very resonant with people who have sort
of chosen the creative life and who find
inspiration for the creative life is
that there's not one answer many things
are sometimes true at once you can be in
the midst of contradiction and not have
that be a stopping point but rather be a
way station on the road forward we've
heard a lot of that kind of language
from him and I think that that's
something certainly that great
literature tries to show us as well that
you know for example to be American is
not one thing to be American is multi
experiential multilingual it is it is
many many many different aspects of the
human experience and that's really part
of what makes this in my opinion an
incredibly interesting country with a
very very vibrant art scene it is that
essence that is not one thing and so I
think that that that comfort with
contradiction is something that we've
seen from the President as well so I see
that as you know fertile ground for the
Arts
you